[Music]
hey everyone i'm tamar hussein managing
editor of gamespot.com and it's my
pleasure to welcome you to the play for
all showcase
brought to you by gamespot and the mix
in this showcase we're going to be
highlighting developers that represent
the bright future of video games
boosting awareness for games and teams
that haven't had as much visibility as
they deserve
more importantly we're highlighting
games and teams that encourage
inclusivity
tolerance and togetherness at their core
all the games in this showcase
are made by a diverse set of creators
that have important stories to tell
these are all games that made us think
smile get excited about
and feel good about what games have to
offer and we hope you feel the same way
too
what is popping everyone my name is
justin woodward co-founder of the mix
the media indie exchange and the
independent game development team in
terra bang entertainment
you guys may not know but the mix and
game spot have teamed up for over five
years now during e3 to showcase some of
the most interesting indie titles that
have graced our screens
with interviews and trailers from
developers from all over the world
this showcase is no exception to the
sentiment that timur expressed
our goal is to really shed light on some
gems hidden or otherwise that you may
not have had the honor of checking out
so with that let's get started with some
up and coming game trailers and hop into
our first interview
with zalavir nelson who will dive into
his new game
el paso elsewhere let's hit it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what is the most powerful drink around
the world
fight with your fists enter your name in
its maker
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's the story about billy the quiet
kid sailing at sea
one morning while fishing the sky
suddenly turns to grey
and all the colors fade away
[Music]
yes
[Music]
uh
[Music]
rainbow billy the curse of the leviathan
i'm in a two-story motel in el paso
texas that gained another 46 stories
yesterday
all below ground
it's extremely bonded
[Music]
and my ex is at the bottom
the rakulei lord of the vampires
[Music]
she's waiting for me
[Music]
would you believe that this is a love
story
i love a person who respects the
classics and we have
salve nelson jr director on el paso
elsewhere
rocking a toe gem an earl's t-shirt
hayden's oliver tell us about a t-shirt
the uh developer of toji monroe gave it
to me uh
i had the fortunate medium he was like
do you want a t-shirt i was like
absolutely uh
and now this is uh one of the most
treasured things that i put on my body
all right all right zollie we're not
here to flex we're here to talk about
your new kingdom
uh el paso elsewhere which is itself a
flex
okay which is a huge flex like i'm
making a game and i've got i told you
i'm an elsewhere
t-shirt wow living the great life so you
you are from strange scaffold a really
cool little uh
studio and you've made a bunch of
exciting games but the one we're talking
about today is el paso elsewhere which
it basically sold me on it the moment i
read the
the description which was supernatural
neo noir third person shooter
i was like i know exactly what that
means but there might be some people out
there who are like what the hell does
that even mean so tell us what does that
mean what is el paso elsewhere it is a
spiritual successor an evolution to
uh classic shooters like
dead to rights max payne and
uh anything that goes bump in the dark
really we're
taking uh noir conventions
and that genre and this very kinetic
physical way of interacting with the
world in slo-mo
and applying that to a nuanced story of
monsters and love and of
uh fighting your way through hell floor
by bloody floor
awesome what other games out there
whether it's a or india are you looking
to be on
you know the obvious inspirations like
max payne as as things that are
inspirational to you
when you're making this game uh
unexpected influence is the die hard
trilogy for ps1
uh i love that game i love that game
that's why we're set to motel and that's
why you're
fighting in this bloody darkened void
not to get too personal but
a huge piece of this project comes from
the idea and the fact that you can be
anything in black these days or at least
that's what you're told you can be
president you can be an astronaut you
can be a game developer
the one thing you can't be is black and
angry that's terrifying that will
terrify
support of white people being black and
angry
being black and justifiably raging
against a world that itself
is destroying not just people who look
like you
not just your family but also
anything that doesn't fit into this very
precise mold of how you are supposed to
behave
so uh long story short
we're making an original hip-hop
soundtrack
including such lyrics as terrorism is
easy be black
in public because there is nothing that
more clearly expresses
um fighting through hell for
by bloody floor than some
good old fashioned hip-hop
oh yeah so i'm hoping that through the
gameplay through the narrative
and through our audio layers we are
delivering the same sense of
freedom of expression and uh critically
feeling badass
even if you're just sitting in your room
in your underwear
yeah it's time it's that feeling of
knowing
you you can be yourself and be okay
because i remember having that same
feeling where i was like
i don't have to keep up with pop music
just to fit in
i can just listen to rap if that's the
only thing i want to do and i remember
i had that kind of uh realization
around the same time until the end of
time came out um
tupac shakur's uh a kind of album and i
just
blasted the [ __ ] out of the album and it
was one of the best like months of my
life
i was just to say this we were talking
to people who don't understand that like
a song like the police isn't like hey
we're going to
jack up the police it is an expression
of i cannot do anything against this
overwhelming fascist force
yeah but i can rap
and you're going to hear every amount of
this this this justified fury and rage
expressed
uh through music
zeliver thank you so much for taking
some time out of your day to talk to us
about el paso elsewhere
hopefully we get to see more of it very
very soon
you know as a big fan of the classic max
payne i am definitely
interested in zeliver's team take on the
genre next up though
we have a developer that hails from the
philippines developing a tasty game for
your senses
you know every time i see a game that
has to do with food in 4k
it makes me want to grab my phone and
hit that doordash button to hop
right in but let's jump into some more
trailers
and tam will interview chikan with soup
pot in our next developer interview
here is a world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
in the past i worked on serious and
political games like headliner
about fake news and its effect on
society following those topics has been
very draining both mentally and
emotionally
i really needed a break something that
would be silly colorful and gameplay
focused
hi my name is jakub and i would like to
tell you about our game
what's a better idea than a game where
you play as a little cloud and ruin
everybody's day
limiting our protagonist to being a
cloud was an interesting design
challenge that actually spurred a lot of
innovation
sure we can rely on weather powers like
rain snow or tornado
what about different rain modes what if
you could rain acid rain and corrode
vehicles
what about raining oil and propagating
fire what about raining coffee into mugs
of tired office workers
and then we realized why limit ourselves
to liquids why not rain bread that
attracts pigeons or hens that can pet
dogs
why not rain swords and go on an epic
adventure solving quests and exploring
dungeons
what if other games got invaded by the
cloud what if you were sneaking through
a compound ala metal gear solid or maybe
silent hill but you're the monster
forcing ourselves to be a cloud gave
birth to many unusual if hilarious ways
of subverting player expectations
always expect the unexpected rain in
your parade is out now
i remember what i can
[Music]
sometimes it's difficult
but when i do remember
[Music]
i remember everything
either the colors the sounds
oh the words
words are how i collect
my memories
they are what tell me i'm still
me
[Music]
i must hold them close
[Music]
before
it's too late
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
cooking is a comforting outlet for a lot
of people and filipino studio chicon
club wants to give you the same
warm and fuzzy feelings from their new
game soup pot
i'm joined by gwen foster who has
requested to be called penguin master
but he's actually a technical director
how you doing gwen i'm doing great thank
you for indulging me
in in that request i like it i'm always
up for a bit of shenanigans so i super
super appreciate you doing that
um so my first question for you gwen is
um tell us about
tell us about support what is it and why
should people be interested in it
uh so one of the things that uh the team
itself like really wanted to do so
originally it was just trina and me
who is the director of the game uh we
wanted
a cooking game that's just really
focused on cooking so you have games
that like overcook
but it's more of management of the
kitchen which is still super fun
you have games like monster hunter that
feature cooking but it's more animation
but there are very few games cooking
simulator is one of them
that are actually focused on cooking
itself so we wanted to recreate that
but the gist is that where we grew up
we actually don't do recipes
and so like it's more of like heart or
feelings or you know
the the voices of your ancestors and we
wanted to have that in the game
so we actually released the demo last
year and people really liked it
so we we made it the bigger game which
is super fun
obviously soup pot is coming from a team
in south east asia
where not a lot of games come from and
that means that you have
a distinct perspective how much of the
how much in terms of when you're
creating the game are you thinking about
hey this is an opportunity for us to not
only put a real cool game out but also
educate
people around the world about our
culture and
i know i for one don't have a lot of
exposure to filipino food and
like now i see this not only as a game
that i want to play but also as an
educational experience how do how much
do you keep that in mind
the thing is that uh and this might
sound corny
is that you know when you're making
something of course start with what you
know
so definitely like we wanted to do a
cooking game
but we want it but you know of course
like if we go
ahead and do like italian cooking we're
not gonna be qualified to do that
uh and so it it's uh it's a good
coincidence in a way because like we
we just generally want like more of our
food
to enjoy and the thing is that we food
the more like we
delve into it and because like we have
dlc's plan that would touch on different
cultures
uh the more we realize that there's just
so many similarities
across the regions that it's really
about ingredients and then like how you
do things
what do you think needs to be done or
what needs to happen
for a region like southeast asia to
become
some kind of powerhouse in its own right
where people don't feel compelled to
work
for companies that are from other
countries but
do what you do and put together a
stronger presence
in the region how how what does the
development community need to do and
what does the people outside of that
people who buy and play games need to do
to support that
i think one of the things that um
hopefully doesn't get me canceled is
that
because we are from this part of region
of the world there
is that like oh this game isn't worth
this much money
and then developers also you know fall
to pray
that like because this
is the notion of games like this that
we are of lesser quality like even
though we're just as talented that they
price their games too low
and then which you know like to a
consumer also thinks it's like oh this
is too cheap
like maybe it's not worth my money um so
that's one thing like both from the
consumer and
players developers perspective like in
terms of business
you see so many innovative games come
out
and like kinder uh and just more fun
games
coming from the west that
people in southeast asia or any other
region
that doesn't have the similar access
they do also have
those ideas but they're not exposed to
funding opportunities they're not
exposed to the right people
and twitter does help but at the same
time
uh you just you know you have to have a
strong
heart and a thick skin to to like
get to a point where you know you
you feel like you deserve it that that
hey
you know i that's basically what
happened to us is that
hey there are no games that don't have
recipes
that literally you know have a cooking
game that has no recipes or it's just
like hey your ingredients do whatever
you want um but but yeah
i think that's that's mainly the thing
that you know people
the developers themselves have to feel
like they deserve it and at the same
time they just have to make a really
great game that
hopefully if you know luck falls on them
is something that everybody will get to
love
and enjoy to play so yeah there's
there's opportunities to
support developers in these regions and
it doesn't mean getting something that's
alien to you it means getting something
that's fresh and unique and
in a lot of cases something that you
already know but coming from a new angle
which is always good thank you
thank you also like this this is super
fun and thank you thank you for
uh giving us this platform and giving us
this opportunity
all hell the penguin master thank you
now i'm extremely hungry for some hot
pot some fur
some ramen some chicken noodle soup i
don't even know we have another set of
sweet
game trailers and reveals for you to
sink your teeth into and then we'll be
talking to the dev team behind the
classic
rpg inspired artistic fever dream she
dreams elsewhere
from davion goodin and studio severe
check out the trailers and we will be
right back
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
laughs
welcome to lahaina a wonder of endless
beauty and nature
let your troubles melt away on this
tropical paradise
relax your mind and soul on one of our
breathtaking beaches
or stimulate your adventurous side with
exciting activities found
all over the island
the aloha spirit will leave its mark on
you and keep you coming again
and again get ready for an unforgettable
experience that is sure to bring you
peace
serenity and plenty of magical memories
lahaina the destination of a lifetime
i will now gauge your interest in
multiplayer
by simulating a multiplayer experience i
am helping we are doing this together
we are friends and this week people bond
by doing activity
i'm gwen frey and this is labrad
good you have unlocked a new puzzle
begin the next puzzle
good work here is your achievement
you are a tester your job is to evaluate
a puzzle game that is being crafted by
this artificial intelligence
i am giving you control of your very own
gun please be responsible
unfortunately the ai has gained access
to more data than we anticipated
and it seems to be generating new games
based on
whatever it finds the place where you
live is dark
and full of crimes
what are we going to do
there are so many guns
you have nothing on me for updates on
the game's progress you can follow me on
twitter
and you can support us by
wishlistinglabrad on steam
or by signing up for the closed beta at
labrad.study
thank you
[Music]
welcome to palm mall we're proud to
welcome you
to your home away from home
grab some friends and head down to
watterson
where you can shop till you drop with
the best deals in town
visit the world famous paradise cinema
featuring wall to wall screens and
unparalleled sound and have a blast with
the whole family
at luna dreamland featuring our newest
most wildest attraction the hall
of mirrors our courteous staff
is here to serve you at all times
after all only the best for our guest
so much variety so much style
what are you waiting for we can't wait
for you to come visit
us palm mall
a place to relax a place to explore
a place to dream
uh indie games are incredibly powerful
because they
often tackle themes topics and issues
that are deeply human
but often sidelined by a lot of the
major big budget titles
she dreams elsewhere is one of those
indie games and is being made by one
incredibly talented person davion
goodin designer director writer and
pretty much everything else
davian thank you for joining how you
doing
uh thanks for having me uh you know the
world's still kind of on fire but other
than that you know i'm vibing
how are you you know what we will get to
the world on fire a bit because there's
an interesting part of your development
that i kind of want to check out but
first like tell us
about she dreams elsewhere what is it
and what do you want to explore with it
yeah for sure um say she james elsewhere
it's a surreal adventure rpg about
dreams nightmares and all types of
self-identity fun stuff
you're playing as a woman named dahlia
and you're in a coma and you gotta
figure out like how you got in a coma
find a way to wake up confront your
inner nightmares
and just have like this horrible trippy
experience the entire way um
say overall it's a game about how it's
like okay to not be okay and like just
you know to reach out to other people
like because you never know what they're
going through
um and you know all the other fun
existential stuff like that
one of my first questions with with this
game was
seeing it was all you doing this alone
um and also
seeing that it's something that hits on
like really personal themes
and we've seen a fair few like
one-person development teams like that
handles heavy subject matter like you
know undertale's an easy one to grab but
what's that process like making a game
on your own but also
for one of a better phrase putting your
pains into that game or your kind of
like
learnings into that game what's what's
that like
and what are the challenges day-to-day
that people might not know because they
just see a game that looks cool and it's
like oh one person development team what
is the true human cost of a one person
development team
it's it's a blessing and a curse because
on one hand like
i've pretty much been able to do exactly
what i wanted to do with this game
um and i'm like a weird guy with like a
lot of like weird ideas
um so let's just kind of like do that
like unfiltered and just like do me
we're normally in like a bigger
development team it'd be like
you know i'd have to like pass like you
know x amount of approvals get past the
marketing department
you know all this stuff um so having
that freedom has been like super
liberating
it's a little lonely sometimes um but
it is fun and i would there's very few
things i'd rather want to be doing
right now um so i'm very thankful for it
but also i'm very
very tired so you mentioned earlier that
um
you know you enjoy having the kind of
autonomy to make the thing your own
but the support is really kind of tricky
thing do you think um
we're getting to a stage where
developing indie games
is is being supported by you know bigger
publishers in a more meaningful way
you know we have the xbox is going out
there to find smaller
developers and and playstation and that
do you think that it's getting better
and
how do you think it could improve the
games industry could improve and support
creators with unique voices so that
there's more perspectives around
i definitely do think it's getting
better like even just to support that
like i've gotten
from you know big platforms like xbox
uh sony not so many nintendo
um you know all these like other
platforms they're just like actually
reaching out for like opportunities and
just like
you know just stuff just to support what
i'm doing that's like dope and i don't
think you would have like seen that
especially for a game like this like
even like five ten years ago
um so that's really a big set with that
being said we still got a hell of a lot
of work to do
um and i think that really comes down to
like
who is like working in the industry uh
who are like the gatekeepers of like
this industry and like
yeah like who is like funding these
projects who's like getting these like
you know deals like signed
um and it's a matter of like actually
like you know going out and like
actively doing the work and like
reaching out
uh to like a more like diverse um like
just creative
uh creative squad actually going out and
like putting your money where your mouth
is and like just funding like actual
projects like not even in like the tens
of like thousands but i'm talking like
millions you know like why why isn't
there like a car woman nights fun
that like xbox has which is like funding
like
aaa games like made by like diverse
teams um i know it's like happening in
the background but like
we could do a lot better i think um
and it's crazy because like even like
developers who are like
they might have like a few more people
than me but like you know we're still
kind of doing the same thing
like the same age like same experience
level like they're still having like
trouble like getting money
so it's like what is happening here
i don't know there's definitely room for
major publishers and platform holders
being louder about doing it because
and giving people avenues about you know
reaching
out to put people put themselves forward
because i feel like
yeah it's happening in the background
but it shouldn't be in the background it
should be in the foreground so that
people who may have these ambitions know
that there is a
path there right there's like almost
like there's gatekeeping by not talking
about it enough
um right and we should be in a in a
industry that is open about it and
welcomes it
um but yeah it's it's i hope that
we get to a stage where that is possible
and hopefully games like she dreams
elsewhere
does kind of help push that kind of path
forward
uh davion thank you so much for taking
the time out of your incredibly busy day
to talk to us about she dreams elsewhere
davion's development journey with she
dreams elsewhere is
is really fascinating he was a part of
the mixes black voice and gaming
freshman class which was super awesome
i'm looking forward to the release
next up we have another set of trailers
and tam will be heating it up with
another spicy interview with spanish
developer
severio and co-founder of troglobites
who will share his team's game
ido no yami blind fate let's get it
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chinatown detective agency where do i
even start
well it's a vibrant neon-lit
point-and-click adventure game
set in a future singapore in the year
2032
it's a dark world inspired by
hard-boiled detective films
comics and novels but out of all of our
sources of inspiration
one tower is above all the classic where
in the world is carmen san diego games
of the late 80s and 90s
and these were the games that inspired
chinatown's most important
gameplay mechanic real research
as you play the role of amira dharma an
ex-cop and interpol
officer you'll encounter cases with
puzzles that will require you to
literally look beyond the game for
answers
that's right you're going to have to
consult google to find the answers to
the puzzles
that cover a range of topics in history
art science and cryptography these cases
will also see you traveling the world
to exotic locations in search of the
next lead or to track down a person of
interest
in essence it's a game that asks you to
be a real detective
we hope you'll join amira as she
unravels conspiracies
and infiltrates criminal syndicates amid
a backdrop of a chaotic world hanging on
by a threat
chinatown detective agency comes out
later this year
on pc via steam and a few other
storefronts
and on nintendo switch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it is my great pleasure to be joined by
the ceo of troglobites game saverio
caprocho
and we're going to be talking about
blind fake edo no yummy a super exciting
anime inspired action game that i love
the look of silveria how are you doing
today
hi damn water i'm fine hello everybody
doing good thank you so much so edo no
yummy tell us a little bit about it
blind fate i don't know yummy i should
say the full name
tell us a little bit about it where did
the idea for it come from it looks super
cool
uh yes thank you the idea of the game
comes
of course by something innovative that
we want to apply in the world of
the video games basically the main
character is
blind so you cannot see the environment
at the same time it's also
a cyborg meaning that he can
receive handled data and with that user
the help of this data
and of the sensors you can perceive the
environment
so you can navigate through the level
and with all these
kind of combinations really cool idea
and will be welcomed by the public yeah
that's a really cool
intersection of two kind of concepts how
does it actually manifest in the video
game you talked about
one character the character being blind
and then receiving data
um can you break it down a little more
so people who might not be
might not understand how that comes
together can kind of get a grasp of how
the game plays
yes there are yes indeed there are some
other concepts
he receives uh data in his brain
about the environment okay so this is
the environment like
let's say google map so you see
everything
but those data are old they are from the
past because it was an apocalypse due to
the narrative there was an apocalypse so
now the
for instance the environment has changed
after so many years
so yes you can trust the data that you
have but you cannot trust totally
because
you know there is a bridge and then this
bridge has collapsed collapses
it does not does no longer exist so you
have to retrieve new data
and guess who is those new data the
enemies
so you have to kill key enemies
there are machines their eyes they
record everything
you have to steal the data from the
enemies
so you can see the world how actually it
looks like
so one thing i really love the look of
is the action can you talk a bit about
the inspirations
and where you kind of are looking to in
terms of other games or other forms of
media and putting together
the action at the core of edunami
yes i mean we took inspiration both from
movies
actually and games i mean the movie
movie about
a blind samurai is satoji
and blind fury if you if you remember
those
those movies and okay the settings you
know the futuristic
settings let's say recalls beat a bit
later just to say
uh strider and uh all the other games
like uh like the ninja guide and
other games that we loved when uh in our
childhood
so who knows we meet together and
there's also one more mechanic to do
with
sensing and senses and smell and that
kind of stuff and it sounded really
fascinating when i was learning about it
can you tell me about it
uh yes sure being blind of course you
see the environment
but you don't see the the things are
moving on and what is inside
for instance something it's hidden so
you have three sensors
the hearing sensor the heat sensor and
the smell
or factory sensor so you can see the
stimulus that are produced by the
enemies or by the environment
now if the enemies are approaching you
you will see
the ripple of the sound of the steps of
the enemy so you see the enemies
approaching you
can react if you're stuck in a room you
can use
the other sensor to find a way out so
yes the mechanic of the sensor helps you
to navigate through the level and to
fight
it's also component to fight the enemies
for
for a developer that is kind of smaller
but
and has this kind of big vision in the
same way that a team like yours has
for blind faith what would you say what
piece of advice would you give them to
take the take the risk or take their
shot at their dream and make a game
that they want to even if they do feel
that they might have some hurdles
because they are smaller developers how
would you empower
those kind of indie developers what
would you say to them
so yeah first of all they in my opinion
they should
learn how to work together during some
uh some
gems there are many participatory to
participate with any gems
then you will see which concept you can
work better which is your
reach in terms of cost time and
production
and then once you have you have a let's
say product you can
you want to work with well at this
moment you can start approaching
if needed a publisher and
yeah to support your vision as you said
so let's start from from very very
small things we did
if if again we did we start with our
first first game is hyper parasite
and then we moved a bit forward in the
world of the indy just because
of course because we were known among
them we
we launched the game so we were able to
collaborate
with one one xp for this game with a
better
bigger aviation that's awesome so
stick together baby steps and you two
can make a game inspired by zatuichi and
strider that looks pretty awesome
thanks siberia thank you so much for
your time super excited to
to see more of the game and check it out
ourselves thank you so much
definitely my type of game i want to
grab my samurai sword do a double
backflip and slice foes in half
with our final interview we will travel
to japan
to the hot springs with our friend derek
fields co-founder of waking oni games to
talk about his soon to be released game
onsen master but first some more slick
trailers and upcoming releases
[Music]
a little too far don't you think it's
time to release the quacking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
talk too big for someone so small you
need to be taught some respect
so let me enlighten you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
at a time where everyone is dreaming of
relaxing in an onsen
derek fields founder and director of
working only wants you to manage one
derek what's going on here all
centered on being a cozy game centered
on um
you know connectivity and and bringing
people together
uh it own semester was deeply inspired
by
a love for um family films especially
ghibli films and i sure i'm sure
saying that out loud for some viewers
they might be able to catch some hints
on
what keenly influenced a game like
managing a hot spring
spirited away is a film that's very near
and dear to myself
my family and it's something that
brought us together on the couch and in
the theaters anytime
those were brought to our city and i it
stuck around with me wanting to create a
game
that could center on those same things
what would it be like to
manage a hot spring to manage various uh
spirits called yokai
and the different humans that are also
visiting your your own sin
all right so you mentioned a bunch of
inspirations for
onsen master earlier and it sounds like
it comes from
a bunch of different you know people and
and perspectives
being involved in this studio and the
game so you
you kind of you've described yourself as
a bipark studio
can you talk a little bit about what
that means and also
what impact that has on on sim master as
you create it
one of the things that i didn't
necessarily have growing up were
games that included characters that were
that were
black and brown it was always
interacting with a protagonist that
didn't necessarily look like me
and so i would love to add into the
games that are now being represented in
media that do have people that look like
us
and be a part of that space do you think
we're getting better and do you think
it's kind of being led by the industry
in indies in the industry
um yes and yes i think things are
absolutely getting better
i think there are certainly more
games out there that are including
people that look like
um like that look like each of us having
this conversation now
i think absolutely indie games are
championing this inclusion and this
representation that needs to be seen
um across the industry as a whole and
because of that there are certainly
more kind of aaa level games that are
including
more uh bipod characters um and some
very notable games too and so
i hope i i you know uh optimistic me i
don't want that to stop i want
to see more i want um i want
just it to continue happening as as
people
i know we said that it's getting better
but it feels like
there's is there a ways for us to signal
to the
broader games industry maybe even the
aaa industry
to be like hey we really want this um
and really break through in a big way
um do you think that's how do we do that
do we just support
um indeed developers or do we i mean
should indeed an indie developer out
there who may be thinking about making a
game
just take the jump and you know do that
thing that they think it might be a risk
yeah um you know when i think of
that conversation there are uh maybe
two or three components that come to
mind um
one is the support of first and foremost
and
um ensuring that we are uplifting other
developers who are
building uh games and narratives that
continue to add to the space of of
including bipod characters
and that also extends to lgbtqia plus
characters as well and
individuals within those games um it
sends a signal it sends a signal on
social media when you start seeing
certain stories being talked about and
how
impactful they are for the community uh
to see themselves represented
um i'm i'm not alone in experiencing
miles morales spider-man and uh how
impactful
having that sort of representation
through and throughout not only the
story but the communities that
miles played in throughout that
narrative
and that's that's an example when you
see resounding feedback from
twitter and so on it's important i think
for the other component you know next to
uplifting is ensuring that we can
provide
resources to indie developers who are
pursuant of that
same endeavor because a lot of the times
people who come from these backgrounds
are marginalized and therefore don't
have the same access to resources
in order to produce these ideas there is
a very
very real cause and effect so yeah
supporting
games where you know there are bipark
lgbtqia plus um
characters is super important thank you
so much for your time derek i think we
could talk about this all day long but
absolutely i'm sure you've got a game
about making people manage onsen teams
i'll let you get back to that but thank
you so much
those are just some of the awesome games
being created by developers around the
world we had everything from
drink cans fighting each other to an
action game with a duck to
a soothing town building simulator and
that's just a small selection of the
amazing experiences that inclusive indie
game developers are making around the
world
before we head off i just want to give a
huge thank you to all the
indie developers and the publishers
working with them who took the time and
effort to create trailers for us and
then talk to us and i also want to thank
everyone at gamespot and the mix for
working so hard over the past few weeks
to put this amazing showcase together
thank you so much yeah tam i mean it's
so many great games uh and developers
that we
shared today um exclusive and inclusive
at the same time which is great the
interviews were amazing
thank you all for joining us thank
gamespot for showcasing these games it
means a lot to the developers
of course i'm also a developer myself um
again my name is justin woodward
from the media in the exchange the mix
at indie exchange and we will catch you
later
[Music]
peace
you